[Music]
I have been looking forward to this one
yes it is true it is time for the Satan
pit and the impossible planet except in
the opposite order because I just said
them backwards but yes it's the
two-parter dealing with the beast from
series 2 this is one of my favorite two
parters and also I've have a nostalgic
connection do it because Satan pit was
the first episode of Doctor of modern
era Doctor Who that I ever saw it's what
made me want to watch the show now I
actually didn't see it from the
beginning I came in I don't know about
15-20 minutes into it and but I mean the
the instant I saw knew it I was like oh
ok what's going on here and then I kept
watching and I was hooked so I've got a
real soft spot for this story but even
aside from that hook in and that
nostalgia I do think this is very good
it's wonderfully atmospheric it's got a
terrific supporting cast that has a
great dynamic and everyone feels like a
fully fleshed out character it's got
effects that hold up surprisingly well
it's it is just you know just dripping
with atmosphere intention and all this
stuff I really do like the heck out of
this everyone's giving Todd Nash
performances it's eurie it's spooky the
beast is intimidating and I will never
get tired of coming back and revisiting
this that said it was funny to go back
and watch because what what I'm noticing
on these re watches is and I've
mentioned this before on episodes that I
usually don't like I'm trying to find
the stuff that redeems them at least a
little you know
something there's like oh well at least
it has that you know that maybe I'd
forgotten or didn't appreciate before
and on the episodes I really like I
can't help but look for you know maybe I
am maybe I have rose tinted glasses on
when I think of this and there are the
story does kinda cheat from time to time
in terms of a few things that a dozen
the way things kind of move forward as
it goes along and what I mean by that is
some of the things that are going on off
hand ball first of all the resolution to
the cliffhanger is lame as it often is
like oh my god the the pits opening and
the planets gotta fall out of orbit and
no wait no the planets not gonna fall
out orbit it no look nothing came out of
the pit so you know there's stuff like
that but also beyond that like the
cold-open
is lame with you gluing we must be we
must feed you if you are hungry like
that's lame and then there then there's
things like the doctor gets the TARDIS
back a I and I can accept him finding
the TARDIS again I'm prepared to go with
that massive coincidence even though it
is admittedly a massive coincidence but
he then you know he's the TARDIS is able
to just fly away from from a black hole
and it's not necessarily that I would
think that TARDIS is incapable of doing
that but it just seems like way too easy
and way too convenient and it makes his
disbelief that's something that a planet
was in geosynchronous orbit around a
black hole from earlier in the story a
little bit disingenuous is like but you
have a machine that could just that
could literally fly circles around a
black hole and you say this planet is
impossible like wait a minute here
so you know there are little things like
that that I can pick up on and I can
spot and they're kind of across the
thing I said every character is fleshed
out there actually I always forget that
they exist because they literally only
exist to die because they're on the
security
team and like they just they do just
kill them in the second thing so like
fair dues there are two complete fodder
characters who I don't even think it
named or have any lines apart from just
like getting the ball stuck on their
head they go so you know there are
little things like that book so now that
I've admitted to someone like the little
flaws niggles nitpicks that could kind
of exist across the thing I'm just gonna
gush for a bit if you don't mind so I
really enjoy the doctors you know
admiration of this group you know it's
like human beings you're amazing and
then at the same time you're also
completely mad you should get your
rocket head home I love that the doctor
never really knows for certain what it
is that he encountered here I like that
even at the very end
he's he won't say what it was you say I
think we beat it and that's good enough
for me
and I actually I really loved the line
when confronted with the beast that he's
that he says I accept that you exist I
don't have to accept what you are but
you what you are but your physical
existence I'll give you that so I really
enjoy that the I I have I go back and
forth on whether or not I sort of
consider the the seeding but it takes
like two years to pay off the idea of
the food as a slave race it does seem
like it was really kind of left behind
for a while but and with how that
eventually pays off I I do think that
I'm prepared to forgive that particular
aspect
I like how three-dimensional all the all
the characters are the the head of
security I really like oh one other
nitpick I'll say is like I actually feel
really bad for him
because it was very obvious that they
added
the muzzle flashes for his gun in
post-production so like he didn't have
blanks going off and so he just had to
shake the gun and it's so obvious cuz
he's holding them it's it's really bad I
feel bad for him that he had to do that
but anyways um you know he he brings a
real sense of past damage which is
something that obviously the beast plays
off of I really like the guys playing
the captain or the interim captain
captain by default kind of at that point
I I like him I enjoy his frustration
with the situation he stuck in I
actually really like Ida I loved her
sense of needing to know of needing to
face the unknown I loved her dynamic
with the doctor you know Danny's a
little bit of a snob but he's also
useful and he's still relatable Toby I
do feel kind of bad for because he he
obviously got he got them he got the raw
deal but also like his scene with the
beast speaking to him and the voice the
beasts the same guy who voiced sue tech
back in pyramids of Mars which is a
trivia fact idol love but you've got you
know Toby sitting them as there's just
this voice
don't turn around if you do and you see
me you will die and it's just playing
off of human nature cuz obviously he's
gonna look and it's you know it's
teasing that out of him and I really
enjoy how that plays as cheesy as it is
I've talked before about the music in
this there is a wonderful melancholy to
it especially like what and the moments
like when Toby is outside on the
planet's surface or they see scooty
floating above the above the living
quarters and it's just there there
there's a real sense of the danger
without the
without the scorer ever having to get
bombastic and I really do appreciate
that quite a bit the doctors got some
phenomenal moments and this is he's got
one of my favorite moments which is him
reaching the end of that table looking
down and seeing nothing but blackness
beneath him and going you know
impossible to tell it could be miles to
go yet or it could be 30 feet I could
survive 30 feet like it's perfect I love
that and like you said it's not a
flawless episode there are little things
across it that I can pick on a nitpick
and depending on what kind tends to bug
you I could even understand how things
like the the things that I mentioned
could bother other viewers more but I
really do love this I love the build
I love the tension I love the payoff it
just it works it works front to back
i-i'll of this cast in it it feels like
a turn to part of that really takes
proper advantage of that of the kind of
story you can tell with that amount of
time with the kind of build you can have
over that amount of time um and it
doesn't over complicate the plot it just
lets things marinate in the atmosphere
of this world and the setting and this
villain hi man I will never get tired of
this
so the impossible planet and the Satan
pit what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff you can do because
there's buttons and links including one
to the patreon if you care to check it
out and help support things like the new
camera that I'm currently using and
hopefully this looks ok this is only the
second video I'm shooting on this camera
you'll see others come out before this
but hopefully it looks decently I'll get
better at it regardless but that's the
sort of thing that the patreon funds and
helps keep going and that sort of stuff
is absolutely appreciated but don't want
to do that there's other links to check
out besides I got a Bo box and a bunch
of other stuff you don't want to look at
any of that that's ok too because at the
end of the day folks
you're the council
and I just run the meetings and until
next time this council is secure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]